a residential street on fire homes
destroyed
a dead woman covered by a plastic sheet
the aftermath of yet another barrage of
Russian missiles in the Ukrainian
Capital cave
husband were literally thrown into the
corridor we regained Consciousness we
heard glass shattering and then there
was an explosion one after another we
ran to the basement now when we came out
into the street we saw ambulances and
there are casualties
foreign this hotel was reportedly only
closed down in recent days it was also
hit by what's believed to have been an
intercepted Russian missile
it was a nightmare it was a massive
explosion we have a strong building but
it's still shook I was standing by the
window and went to the corridor and hid
I can't believe it was so close
in another neighborhood police gather
shrapnel near a two meter deep Crater of
a single building isn't partially
destroyed
people rushed to repair their windows in
the winter cold
the third consecutive day Russia has
launched missiles or so-called Kamikaze
drones
Ukrainian capital and numerous cities
across the country
Olek was with his wife Tatiana in their
sitting room it was a sudden deafening
blast
open we fell to the floor I injured my
head my husband's face was cut it was
terrifying what can we do now it's cold
and we're afraid of more strikes it's a
constant fear
there was a crash and glass flu I was
afraid from my wife more than myself
a blood covered Pavement in a park where
children play
shock fear and the terrifying
uncertainty of not knowing where the
next one will land
scenes of utter Devastation in this
residential neighborhood the level of
the destruction here it's incredible
that more people weren't injured or
killed this is New Year's Eve in the
Ukrainian capital
Stratford Al Jazeera Cube